let's get started with Coursera the
architecting with Google cloud platform
specialization on Coursera comprises six
courses as shown when your email address
has been added you will get an
invitation email to start learning on
Coursera open the google cloud Coursera
invitation email the email has the
subject line join the associate cloud
engineer track offered by Google cloud
in the email click join now to join the
associate cloud engineer track you will
then create or sign into your Coursera
account and agree to join the program
enroll in the first course Google cloud
platform fundamentals core
infrastructure courses have videos
hands-on quick labs and quizzes the
courses provide an in-depth explanation
of key concepts through videos you then
learn to apply the concepts by
practicing with hands-on labs here's my
colleague philip meyer giving you an
overview of quick labs
hello and welcome i'm philip mayer a
course developer with google cloud
platform and this is a brief tutorial on
using quick labs in this course i'm
about to show you the interactive
hands-on labs platform called quick labs
which is part of google cloud quick labs
allows you to get practical hands-on
experience with GCP and provisions you
with Google account credentials so you
can access the GCP console at no cost
the first step is to log into Coursera
in an incognito window depending on your
browser it may also be called private
browsing or in private browsing logging
into Kucera from a private window
ensures that you don't accidentally use
your own Google account while accessing
the Google Cloud console we don't want
you to get any unexpected bills at the
end of the month check out the links
below this video for different browser
support articles once logged into
Coursera using an inconvenient window
return to your course and go to the lab
activity page so if prompted you want to
accept Dioner code and you might even
have to enter your name then you want to
click the open tool button to open the
lab in a new tab so within the new tab
you can now click start lab
and you want to wait until the lab
running is displayed for each lab you
will have a timer in the top right with
the remaining access time your lab will
automatically end when the timer runs
out on the left you have the connections
detail click open google console and
then sign in with the username and
password provided in the connections
detail pane so I'm going to copy the
username paste that in here I'm also
going to take the password paste it in
here too now quick labs creates a new
account for you each time you launch a
lab therefore you need to click through
the initial account setup windows so
essentially I need to accept this I
don't need to add any recover phone
number so I can just click done I'm
going to agree to the terms and services
and I don't need any emails now I can
verify that I'm using the quick labs
provided account and project within the
GCB console so up here I see the project
ID and over here I can see the username
and these are the same ones that I was
provided with in the connections detail
pane you can also see that the timer is
still running now some labs track your
work within the quick laps provided GCP
project if this is enabled you'll see a
score in the top right corner of the
code labs window as you can see right
here your score increases as objectives
are met and you can click on the score
to view the individual steps to be
scored now that I have completed the lab
I can see my score has been updated and
I'm ready to click end lab once I click
end lab the quick labs provided project
and any resources within that project
will be deleted I can close a quick Labs
lab page and my grade will be updated
with my lab score in Coursera
that's it for this tutorial remember to
launch Coursera in an incognito window
and use the quick laps provided
credentials to sign into the GCP console
good luck with the labs and enjoy the
rest of this course to summarize
complete the architecting with Google
cloud platform specialization on
Coursera practice with hands-on labs on
quick labs and review related product
documentation